oh I know I know my answer and I think I know your
answer I think this is easy abortion is worse than
slavery one two three yeah for sure I don't think
abortions worse than slavery how not because I
think there are cases when abortion is acceptable
well and there's no case where slavery is correct
okay there's a couple ways to approach this
but let's take it the first one when do you
think abortion would be acceptable um early
on very early on also if there's like some
severe deformities where the kid is not going
to survive those are cases when abortion is
acceptable why would you say so I mean why do
you think that that would be acceptable then
let's say because those are too distinct for sure
I'm just giving two cases where I would say those
things are far more acceptable than slavery but it
wouldn't you wouldn't say it's acceptable to kill
you you wouldn't say it's acceptable to have
an abortion in the first trimester objectively
you're just saying it would be more acceptable
than slavery no I I'm for I am pro-choice early
on although decreasingly so given uh uh it's it's
kind of very um disturbing to me as a life of a
New Yorker to see how many of these slippery
slope arguments across different issues have
not only been validated but like not only they
put butter and margarine on that slope they also
but I Can't Believe It's Not Butter so it's
just like that thing is so it's greasiness
because it's got seed oils on it and the seed
oil poison yeah um but because my argument
my argument that that I think would be acceptable
within a kind of libertarian or anarchistic
framework for why abortion is always worse than
slavery is that abortion always ends a human life
even if it's a deformed person or even if it's
very early stage human life and that the right
to life is not merely one right among many but it
is it is the fundamental right without which the
other rights cannot exist Kamala Harris just had
this this great quote the great philosopher of our
time Kamala she was she was giving a speech at a
pro-abortion rally and she said you know in our
in our Declaration of Independence we're promised
we're promised certain things we're promised the
right to liberty and the pursuit of happiness
I kid you not yes you say wait what was the
that came before uh liberty no no I think it was
before the yada yada the good part yeah the the
right too uh Liberty not what did you just call
what did I just hear and so you know you can't
pursue happiness without Liberty and you can't
have Liberty without you don't pursue happiness
without Liberty you think so how can you pursue
anything without Liberty because there are people
who are in horrible places like I talk about my
book I've been to North Korea who are pursuing
happiness but oh when I say Liberty I I mean it
more in a in the kind of Christian sense of the
term where you one can never take away the liberty
of one's mine oh yeah okay right that is a priest
precondition to assuming happiness yes and so if
if slavery is a question of Liberty an abortion
is a question of life and doesn't the question
of life always have to take precedence over the
question of Liberty yeah but I do think there are
certain cases we're taking first of all I don't
agree necessarily that early abortion is a human
life uh second of all and that's a whole I know
everyone yes yes ignore the comments thank you I'm
sure there's something never heard before um but
I I the fact that it's sometimes to me acceptable
whereas slavery is so beyond the pale and I also
love the idea I can just hear the comments right
now that people even though that was the question
are going to tell me that me being against
slavery's virtue signaling because you know that
I'm against it because he brought it up I didn't
bring it up spontaneously I brought it up in
response to the question I like I like the idea
that it's not people aren't going to be upset with
you for being in support of abortion in some cases
right isn't it it's that you're against slavery oh
look at this that's the internet for you I've got
to get heat for that yeah well okay all right well
I guess listen I guess I got that wrong I mean I
think I got the question right but I I got your
intuition wrong maybe we slide down the slippery
slope six to 12 more months maybe my answer will
be correct by them I am just gratified that these
different states that are enacting pro-life laws
are basically declaring themselves anathema to
awfuls affluent white female liberals because
it's like this isn't your culture stay where you
belong and that to me is the most important aspect
of pro-life movement that's true hey you know not
most important but a very important one but it is
it's funny you mentioned that because the pro-life
movement I mean there were Democrats in the
pro-life movement they're they're leftists in the
pro-life and which I sometimes even forget because
I think it's all Conservative Christian Republican
type people but there is something I think
compelling as we see a political realignment going
on to just people looking at and they say well
the people on the pro-abortion side they're just
terrible they're just wrong about everything I
found myself pro-choice really because first of
all if we're in its day and age where pro-choice
means nine months I'm out of here yeah of course
this is not an argument like what are you talking
about you know Dave Rubin last I talked to him
on this issue he was pro-choice he was totally
fine with abortion and I've noticed over the
years he he I say well so when do you think
it's acceptable and he keeps pushing that date
back you know and I I think it's he's following
that I think he's following the logic of abortion
as he thinks about these things but I think a lot
of it also has to do with wait a second so these
people who are ostensibly on my side of this
question they're wrong about everything
else you know that was that was actually
ugly and and physionomy is never wrong but the
other thing is it's also different once you have
a kid that's so when there's a face and it's like
oh then it's complete you know but Uncle now it's
not the same as being a dad obviously but it's
just like okay there's a similarity yeah there's
things there's like okay okay I had I mean I I
know plenty of women who have had abortions and
some early some very late and I I did have
this thought because I you know I have two
two kids one just turned two the other one is
six seven months old and I was holding my little
infant baby and I was thinking especially a couple
months ago I'm thinking he doesn't look that
different than he did in the in the belly like
that they could it's like this isn't you know they
tell you the pro-abortion people they tell you oh
it's you can't see the baby on a microscope and
it's all just a complete lie I mean you can see
these are like real they got their little fingers
by like nine weeks or something very that's
true when you see seeing is believing I guess